the md80 passenger jet was a workhorse
for American Airlines for 36 years in
2003 American had 362 of them in its
fleet but time caught up with the plane
nicknamed the mad dog American retired
its final 26 this week replacing them
with newer more efficient aircraft
we asked Kris Van Cleave to find out
what happens when a jets flying days are
over
good morning this is the Roswell Airport
it's known more for the planes that
never take off than the ones that do
they call it a boneyard it's where
planes whose flying days are done are
parked and they're parked here by the
hundreds 94 think you got people up here
watching so make it a good one so big
off this will be the final takeoff for
American Airlines flight 94 66 the
painted early morning sky for the last
time as it flies from Dallas to Roswell
New Mexico retirement flights are
special typically there are only pilots
we're about the only passengers on board
which means we do have our pick of seats
captain Dave Clark was at the controls
after 50 3563 flight hours and
approximately 3.2 million passengers
since it first took off with his final
entry in the plane's log Clark closed
the book on Americans and dat fleet an
old friend of his for 27 years
you know this day is coming for a while
but to realize this is your last take
off your last landing this is the last
time you sign the logbook shut the
engines down it's a little surreal
that's it one by one the parade of
planes the last of the airline's md-80s
landed in Roswell rolling to a stop
side-by-side American Airlines CEO Doug
Parker has brought in more than 500 new
planes in the last six years we now the
youngest fleet of all the network
airlines this is what happens when you
bring in new airplanes old airplanes
come out of the desert
two dozen retiring planes in a day is
unusual but this is literally where old
planes are put out to pasture the hot
dry air Ward's off rust preserving the
aircraft
from old 747s to a private jet that once
belonged to Elvis row after row a
sprawling testament to the planes of
yesterday so many you can see them from
space is Roswell the end of the line for
most of these planes for most of the
airplanes yes Brian Hancock's company
Kabu aerospace buys old airliners they
sell the engines and strip the plane of
in-demand parts what percentage of this
plane will end up getting reused so with
the processes and procedures that are
used today we are up in the 90
percentile retirements not so great for
the rest smashed into pieces and sold
for scrap but Dave Hall sees a certain
beauty here it's quiet you hear time
passing these planes by it's got this
really eerie kind of feeling
it's a boneyard slash graveyard it's
something romantic about it in the same
sense you know to come out here and walk
amongst these Giants for nearly 20 years
he's been taking pieces of all planes
and turning them into something new this
mba detail they're cutting up today goes
to Hall Southern California workshop
where his company moto art will turn it
into furniture that borders on art a
sofa this mile-high bed or his
bestseller these tables I felt like was
really kind of like our duty to kind of
deserve aviation history a little bit
history that for now is grounded
American expects some of the planes that
were retired this week to fly again for
a different airline in different colors
but most of these planes will be parted
out and recycled some will sit here
parked in the New Mexico desert for
years to come for CBS this morning Kris
Van Cleave Roswell New Mexico
you think about how many flights they
made how many people that carry well the
ambition the opportunity they
represented and now they're quiet yeah
be like a little Museum in that area